hey pals it's April 24th I'm chassis
with your news for today Before we jump
in subscribe to us on YouTube let's hang
out in the comments and talk because I
read all of those commas I sure do
anyway thanks for subscribing let's jump
into today's stories first up three new
overwatch maps are likely coming this
year overwatch was released 11 months
ago but has only gotten two new standard
maps used in quick play and competitive
play modes you can expect to see even
more than that over the remainder of
this year in response to a forum thread
discussing the frequency of new map
releases overwatch director Jeff Kaplan
revealed that the three standard maps
are in development and our quote past
the initial play testing phase he added
while something could always change all
three of those are looking likely for a
release this year Kaplan also noted that
three non-standard maps are in
development but he didn't comment on how
far along they are or whether we'll see
any of them this year these maps aren't
intended for quick play or competitive
play which could mean they're intended
for arcade modes as was the case with
the arena mode only echo point
Antarctica finally in a very nonspecific
fashion he teased we also have a few
other experiments going on hopefully
this will satisfy some of what you're
looking for he concluded we want to play
on these maps as badly as you guys do
we'll work as fast as we can overwatch
is currently in the midst of its latest
limited time seasonal event uprising
along with new cosmetics this features a
special PvE mode not entirely unlike the
one release for Halloween next up get
ready for long load times with sniper
ghost warrior three it takes up to five
minutes Eurogamer made a video
illustrating just how long it takes to
go from the main menu to the in-game
action in sniper ghost warrior 3 on ps4
it compares this particular instance a
weight that takes four minutes and 50
seconds against the amount of time
needed to do other things such as a
speedrunning gone home or completing a
race in mario kart 8 deluxe our reviewer
has also experienced similar problems in
terms of near five-minute load times you
can look for gamespot's full review
tomorrow the long load times can
possibly be attributed at least in part
to ghost warrior three adopting an
open-world style leaving behind the more
linear nature of its predecessors
ahead of its release tomorrow a new
patch has been released that addresses a
variety of technical issues but lo times
don't appear to be among the problems
fixed in the update speaking with
GameSpot CI games acknowledge the long
initial load times but said that this
approach allowed it to shorten any
loading times during missions responds
and fast travel to a minimum it
estimates that the fast traveling takes
four to 15 seconds loading the last
checkpoint takes 15 to 30 seconds and
restarting a mission takes 25 seconds
ultimately we feel like this
inconvenience is rewarded with a
comfortable experience once the game is
loaded it added we don't know how the
game performs on pc or xbox one yet and
we will keep you updated when the game
comes out tomorrow and finally is
today's Bayonetta update teasing a
vanquished PC release owners of the
recently released PC version of
Bayonetta received a minuscule update
today and it has fans of another
platinum games developed title excited
as recorded on both the steam forums and
neogaf a 22 kilobyte update released
today adds a small file to bayonet as
extras folder inside is an avatar
showing Sam Gideon the protagonist of
vanquish there have long been calls from
fans for a PC version of vanquish which
was only ever released for Xbox 360 and
ps3 when it was launched back in 2010
the sudden steam release of another
older platinum game 2009's Bayonetta may
have opened the door for that's have
finally happened it seems entirely
possible that this image was intended as
a tease given that bayonet his pc
release was itself for his teased with
something hidden in a free 8-bit
Bayonetta game that launched on April
Fool's Day vanquish earned acclaim when
it was released back in 2010 and has
become something of a cult classic
there's not yet any official word from
platinum or publisher Sega about a
vanquish release but we'll report back
if any of that changes hey titanfall 2
fans be sure to join us tomorrow for a
live stream where we check out the new
DLC called a glitch in the frontier
we'll be checking out a new map at 11am
pacific time so don't miss it and if you
want to hang out with me i'm over on
gamespot universe and Jess will be back
tomorrow gamespot universe is our place
for all things movies TV comics anime
wrestling all the things you like so go
join me there and I'll see you